メリークリスマス、みんな。
はじめしゃちょーです
12月の24日、クリスマス、イブでございます
っと、皆さま御存知のとおり
なんか、クリスマスっていうのはやっぱね
男女のね、男と女の
（チュッ、チュッ、チュッ）
どう説明すればいい?
12月24日なんですけども
1年間で最も男女が…
(チュッ)
イチャイチャする(笑)、日でございます
性の6時間、といわれております
いろーんな人がね、男女で
ラブラブしてるわけですよ
どういうことだ。
僕たち的には許せないんすよ
許せない。
そう、俺たちが、遊戯王カードしてる間も
やつらはもう…
でも我々はこっちの"せい"を大事にしたいんすよ
クリスマスってのは聖(セイント)、聖夜だから夜だからさ
こっちの性よりこっちの聖を大事にしたいので
俺たちは、俺たちなりのクリスマスを楽しもう。
俺たちのせいの6時間は、
静かなる静の6時間ということで、
今から、6時間、正座します。
性の6時間の間は
はい、というわけで
6時間、正座、スタートです
25日の3時まで、聖の時間を貫きまーす
これどうなるんだろう…
ちょ、待って…
も～、待って…
じゃあ、俺は今日6回死ぬと
www
あ、それでお坊さんたちはやるのかねぇ
今年のクリスマスは…、雨がひどうございます
ざまあ
自分の、好きな、その、人がいたんですよ
うぅん…
その人がなんか、なんかくっついてきてくれて
わ、やばぁ!
写真撮れたんですよ
その時は気づかなくて、終わった後に
写真撮ってくれた人ー、が俺のところに来て
あれ、お前肩に…
髪の毛ついてるぞ、って言われてー
それを持ってー、密封してー、今家に持ち帰ってます
気持ち悪いー
まだあんの?
まだあります
チwwwww
や、なんかー
でも、いずれ、クローン、ができる、
あぁ、時代が…
時代が来たら
バ、バイオテクノロジーで来るかもしれないね…
来たらー
またその髪の毛で、その人ができれ、たら…
あぁ、確かにたまんないねー
でも、もし、その髪の毛が、洗濯し終わった後の母親の髪の毛とかだったら…
それお、お母ちゃんがもう一人…(笑)
お母ちゃんがもう一人出てきちゃう…(笑)
これしびれる原因が血が止まってるだったら
俺本当に、両足…
あれだよ、もう、お、おじゃんだよ
血流が悪くなる…
あぁぁああっ
悪くなってるだけです。
いや、待って待って待って…
いや、これ本当に俺大丈夫なのかなぁ…
血が止まってても
ちょっとググりながらやろう
とりあえずなんか、血が、通んなくて、やばいです今…
血流が悪くなって、なんか、おかしなことになるとかは?
良いことが…
眠くはない
認知症…?　か…
良いことしかないです
え、じゃあこの足のしびれは、なんにぃ?
正座、しびれ、死、みたいな…
なにぃ!?
コツが4つある…
はいはいはい!
コツ…
はい!
はい
は、バカ～(笑)　空気椅子やんけっ
あぁぁ～
靴脱いでいい?1回。　っちょ、靴脱ぐ
あぁでもかなりね、負担はなくなったよ
多分、靴がね、刺さってた
今のでだいぶ楽になりました
靴脱ぐ…、あとは?
これ…?　でー、う、嘘じゃん
wwwww
22時になりました
1時間経過したとっ、ころで感じたのは
足が、もう限界です。
そろそろやめたいぐらいなんですけれどもー
俺は負けたくありません
戦います。
乾杯
あぁ～
ちょっと待って…、ちょっとカイロ、カイロ増加…、死ぬ…
すいません、ちょっと寒さも限界なんでカイロ追加します
ぅあはんはんはんは～ん(泣)
寒いよぉぉぉ(泣)
あ、はっはんはんはんあはぁ～(泣)
まだ死の危機は感じてないんすか?
いやぁ～きついぞぉ
あ、あぁ゛ぁ゛あ゛っ
はい、23時
2時間経過しました
ぅあぁぉぁー!!
たぶんここが今、一番頑張り時だと思います
しびれは、もういいです
許容しました
なんかしびれを越して足、首とかの筋の伸び方が異常で
この先歩けるか不安なレベルです
あと寒いです
ではもう4時間、頑張ります。
うわ、これ、ちょっと待って…
俺ちょっと限界かもしれない…
2時間て･･･、LINEだと思うんだよ
へへ、ははは…
もうすでに限っ界じゃないですか、もう
これやばいわもう…、動かすあの、微調整も効かない今…
12月25日になりました～　メリークリスマース!
(拍手)
おめでとうございます!　みなさんおめでとうございます。
はい、というわけでみなさん今年もね
クリスマス、ぜひね、恋人同士で、楽しみましょう!
トイレだけ行かせてください、すみません
待って待って待って…
wwwww
ガチガチ、これ
待って待って…(笑)
いひっひっひwwwww
いぃ゛っ…
トイレだけお願いします、すみません
ちょっと行ってきます
というわけで5分から再びスタートします
正拳突きよりきついと思うよ
あれ動いてんじゃんだって
こっちは静だからよ
他のカップルは?
あいつらは性。俺たちは静。
あはははぇおヴぉおヴぉ
もうちょっと寒すぎて限界なので
ちょっとおでんを、食べまーす
ただ正座はずっとするので、安心してください
いただきます
あっつあっつ!!
あつっ!
あつ!
あっつ!!
あははははwwwww
とぅ、とぅ・・・
あぁもう、もうお前失格だよ、もうもう失格だからそこで
とぅを言わないと死ぬから、本当に
今日のセカンドチャンヌーは?　(全員)なんと、なんとですね
次回の動画もよろしくちゃん　(全員)次回の動画もよろしくちゃん
指スマ10･･･
おぉ、おぉぉぉ!　出てきた!　やったぁやったぁ、よし!
指スマ25。
あははははwwwww
指スマ20!
www
はい、1時になりました
4時間、経過したわけなんですけれども
徐々に、そのクリスマス、で
イチャイチャする恋人に対する憎しみが消えつつ
指スマゲームも楽しくできるようになってきました
ありがとうございます。
ただ…、足は痛いです!
1時32分です　あと、1時間半でございます
ね…、えへへ…
えへへへへへ…(笑)
はい!
12月25日、午前2時となりました!
素晴らしいでございます皆さま
素晴らしいでございます、素晴らしいです…
いよいよ、静なる6時間も残り1時間となりました
もう悔いはありません。
もうここまでくると
痛みとかは…、もう常に痛いんですよ
常に痛いんですけれども
なんかもう自分が誰か、ここがどこかというのが
ちょっとよくわかんなくなってきちゃって
心が、洗われる気持ちです
頑張りましょう!
プルンプルン(↗)　プルンプルン(↘)
プルンプルン(↗)プルンプルンプン(↘)
プンププルン、ププルン、プンプルン…
はははははwwwww
日本の未来は
WoW WoW　WoW WoW
世界がうらやむ
いぇいいぇい　いぇいいぇい(笑)
恋をしようじゃないか
WoW WoW　WoW WoW
2時、半でございます
もう、あのー、残り30分に差しぃ迫ってなんですけども
身震いと眠気、吐き気、頭痛が止まりません
あぁ!　最後は男の勝負だ!
さむぅぅぅさむさむ…(泣)
ふぅ～
はい!
静の6時間…、終了でございます。
(拍手)
実に清々しい気分です
なんか…、LOVEみたいなのをすべて
断ち切ることができました
我々は今後も
せい(聖、静)人として、この世に君臨しようと思います
あぁ…